all right let's go straight to the
phones today let's go
to alana in colorado springs alana
what's going on how are we doing
i'm good how are you doing i'm doing so
good how
is everything in the colorado springs
area
oh it's lovely no complaints here it's
so gorgeous one of my best friends on
planet earth my friend craig lives there
and
man every time i visit it's i get
jealous it's just such a stunning place
very cool very lucky so what's up how
can i help
um so i am looking for ways to reconnect
with my husband
um and i've heard you speak um on past
episodes about
taking retreats annually with your wife
um
so sort of do inventory and discuss your
marriage and i was interested in
learning more about that
very cool so um tell me about your
husband
um so he is in the military and um
he will be returning from deployment at
some point in the next
um in the near future and um
i love how you did that like next week
late soon
eventually at some point one day
that was such a i'm not even gonna say
anything well well done that was awesome
if you work with military families or
you are a military family you are
laughing to yourself right now if you're
not
just recognize they live in limbo and
these poor spouses who are at home
are carrying a lot a lot of stuff on
their shoulders and so
um we're grateful for you alana okay so
he's coming back at some point and go
ahead i cut you off
um yeah so we've been married for eight
years um
we have a five-year-old and a
two-year-old so on top of just the
physical separation
you know we've been spending the last
five years um
with a bunch of crazy people in our
house um
keeping us awake and yelling so um i
think
just with the um i'm i work
also so we both have pretty high stress
jobs
um and i think the most difficult part
of deployment
is when they come home and trying to
reintegrate
because over several months you really
change who you are as a person you
have new experiences and you don't get
to share them in real time
with your spouse and so um it really we
had a pretty hard time last time he came
home
tell me about that tell me about the
hard time um so
i was um a full-time student and doing
an internship
um my son was two and i was pregnant
um and he was gone for several months he
came back
a week before my due date um so we had
integration
plus a new baby um and so
it was um and we have part of the issue
is that we have very different parenting
styles
okay so that's a big source of conflict
for us and we
um between his last coming home from his
last deployment and when he left
last year um we've really been working
on um
that together and um trying to
we've we've made a lot of progress but
it still is
it's a source of of worry just for me
um and yeah and just
i i feel like we kind of don't we
we live together we cohabitate but we've
just lost
some of the like fun parts of being
married yeah yeah
so um you've got a couple
you got a double or even triple whammy
here and so i want to
pull it apart a little bit not give it
the full
and we could do a whole show on this and
maybe we will someday
um an entire show dedicated to veterans
and their spouses
and leaving and coming back and even
just the day-to-day stuff the identity
stuff
all of that wrapping itself up into
this little package called marriage and
what have we been doing together right
but today i want to pull a couple of
pieces apart number one
you know this but i just want to
reiterate if your husband
was the most high functioning connected
at home all the time and he was just an
accountant
having two little kids in your house is
just
shake it just everything changes right
and so you put that sort of deployment
on top of
i mean that's sort of a turn on top of
that you put all of the
political stuff all of the safety stuff
all of the identity stuff
all that goes into this big thing but it
underlies
man your house was already right already
just like a snow globe that somebody
shook up and so what i want to to
encourage you to do this time
the best you can it's gonna be hard the
best you can
is to both of you but you can only
control you right
to to be open about doing this one new
and not bringing any of what happened
last time not bringing any of the we hey
we had these fights it was crazy
let's start completely fresh here okay
and you may have to write stuff down you
may have to be intentional about i'm
nervous he's going to be coming home in
two weeks or one week and last time he
got home and he didn't sleep and he was
loud or whatever
his challenges were reintegrating um
and so when he gets back is he gonna is
he getting out or is he gonna stay in is
he gonna have a job on a base here
yeah he he will have a job when he gets
back um oh he's staying in
okay standing so his identity will still
be he's still be military
right he's not gonna have to also that's
a whole other shift from
military to civilian okay so here here's
a couple of things
you said you've been working on your
parenting styles they're different is it
fair to say you both love your kids
you just love them the picture of what
love looks like is different for both of
you and you're trying to merge that
picture is that fair
absolutely okay so when you say you're
scared or nervous that word picks my
like it it peaks my interest what are
you scared or nervous about
is he a yeller and you're a hugger is he
one
there to have four corners when they
make their bed and you just don't really
care about like
what are you nervous or scared about
yeah i would say
that's that's pretty much it um we both
know that we
fall on opposite ends of the spectrum um
and so he's very positive about it like
balance each other out
um but it's still i
it's yeah it's still a challenge for me
and i think part of it too
is letting go of um being
the parent um solo for nine months and
letting him parent again that's that's
also a challenge
yeah so here's a couple of things i want
to challenge you guys too number one
i want you to start and this is gonna
sound cheesy
i want you to start dating again long
distance
okay and what you're gonna what i want
you all to focus on is
you're gonna build a totally new
marriage you're gonna build something
you've already got some great
foundations to it you've got a history
to get you got almost a decade together
right
you got two kids but i want you to build
a new adventure together and
look at that as an opportunity not as a
chore okay
it could be super exciting but i want
you all to start dating again and start
intentionally being
flirtatious start intentionally being
like what could this look like not what
is it gonna be does that make sense
and it sounds tiny and you hear those
those analogies where somebody's driving
and if you just turn the wheel
one degree you end up turning all the
way around was it
what book was i reading recently maybe
it was james clear's book that says the
the take off from
if you're at lax and you're going to go
to washington dc or you're going to
well maybe it was boston the difference
in it was
seven feet that's how different that no
the nose angle that plane is to get you
from
oh it's new york city to washington dc
right so i'm talking little bitty things
but
hey i want to imagine what our romantic
life is going to be like
i want to imagine what waking up next to
each other is going to be like i want to
go ahead and let's
could we get not pre-marital counseling
but can we go ahead and set up some
counseling where we can learn how to be
married again and what we're going to
build get a common language and
accomplish
things together but you see what i'm
saying i want this to be an exciting
awesome moment like a reset not a how is
he going to fit into our life
does that make sense yes and the biggest
challenge folks have
not the biggest there's a bunch of
challenges reintegrating but one is you
just nail it
you've got a life right it's not one
that you love you'd love him to be
around
but you got a life of man your kids have
a routine you all do things in a certain
way
they come to you for clothes and laundry
you'll have everything and then you try
to figure out how to shove him into that
when he gets
back that's the cause of so much
conflict so rebuild it from the floor up
the second thing is give me two or three
things that you love about him
oh he is incredibly smart
he loves his kids
and he takes really good care of us okay
none of that had to do with
y'all too
you gave me three different things one
attribute about his cognitive ability
and two performance slash achievement
based things
what do you love about him he makes me
laugh
let me ask this a little more um pg-13
what gets your heart beating again
um he always thinks i'm beautiful
he tells me all the time does he show
you
yes okay and when he says you're
beautiful and he shows you're beautiful
he looks at you across the room in that
way that you know
who that gets your heart beating faster
again
yeah do you miss that
yes are you excited for that to return
when he gets back
i'm very excited yeah okay and i know
that part's hard because you got to shut
that off right
you got to completely turn that off
that's why i want you all to start
dating again
okay and the things that you love about
him i want you to focus on not the
achievement things the things he's going
to bring back
but i want you to focus on him right
and then the third thing is is i really
this sounds so cheesy so here's some
things that we do
on that my wife and i do on our on our
retreats together
as we look in the in the past with that
past year the things that have gone well
things have been hard
right this is going to be a little bit
different you don't have to go back if
you don't want to
um but you can go back and say hey in
the past this has been tough this has
been tough i want this to be like this
right and then we spend some time
on what is this year going to look like
if we could if it could be as perfect as
we wanted what would it look like
what are some savings goals how much do
we want to pay off on our house
how much do we want to go trips together
what's our week going to look like every
week i want to make sure we're building
in times for us to connect throughout
the week and then we'll let the week
fill in on behind that
so depending on what his job is there
but we set some
here's who we want to be we want to be
we've been my wife and i have been
together gosh 18 or 19 years
we want it to be like we want to make
sure we're still flirty
we want to make sure we're still
laughing we had a hilarious food fight
the other night in our house
and right when i drilled my son with
like a like a
half-eaten banana and he threw it back
and it blew up all over me i watched my
wife dude
she in like exhaled and i could see it
like cut and then
it's almost as though she remembered oh
yeah we're having fun
and then she's like you're cleaning it
up and then she got involved like
so it was those we set those parameters
we want to be folks who are just silly
again right
and he may say i want to have some
higher structure than last time
but what you're doing is you're being
engineers and architects for
the future not complaining and whining
about the past
and not being anxious about it is he
going to fit in our thing you have to
rebuild a whole new thing
and your kids bring them along not for
the romantic part not for the discussion
of who we're going to be as a couple
but bring them along when he gets back i
want you all to
um have a canvas right i should have
brought mine i didn't know we were doing
this but
i have a canvas at our house that we did
with our kids
and it's our family core values like who
are we and
we say yes and we have adventures and we
treat each other with dignity and
respect
and we have uh we are hospitable we
always have
crazy people staying at our house and so
whenever
i'm like hey son let's go out and play
in the creek and he's like i don't know
dad i'll say
hey we're adventurous uh stallone is
adventurous and he's like okay
that's who we are and then we head out
but inviting the kids into that
to as a part of this rebuilding together
i love it so here's the thing
really focus on him start dating each
other again
go ahead and get somebody go ahead and
get a professional and hope
some military guys aren't into that guy
military guys if you're listening to
this
it's cool man go see somebody to help
you learn a new language this is just a
new set of
skills doesn't mean you're broken
doesn't mean um you're dysfunctional
it means hey i'm gonna pick up some new
tools i've been gone a year i'm gonna
help
get some coaching as i re-enter this and
then build
something new together right don't try
to drag the past
forward and see if he can plug into your
existing world now let's rebuild
something new
it's going to be incredible alana i want
to know when he gets back
i want you both to give me a call let me
know how things are going and then we
can check in and see how things are
rocking and rolling
and see if i might be able to help along
the way but the fact that you're calling
now tells me
man it's going to be so good i want to
thank your husband for his service i
want to thank you for being
a rock star of a mom holding it down
there in colorado springs
and i can't wait to hear your story
about y'all getting reconnected it's so
good